okay so hello everyone my name is
all-sufficient I come from all X and
I'll give you a deep dive into Agassi
books today so let's start and we'll
start with some theory and the roadmap
of the theory looks like this our first
talk a little bit about a simple
classifier decision tree then the
decision tree makes two kinds of error
either bias writer ones or the variance
right at once and there are certain and
sounds methods but allow you to
compensate for these errors and
basically actually boost is like a
concatenation of them all and more and
that's the final stage of our
theoretical journey to EXCI post okay so
very classical example from one of the
machine learning books you have some
features describing the weather and
you'd like to know if it is weather is
good to play tennis or no and based on
these features with some classic
algorithms that use certain measures
like Gini index or entropy for
informational gain ratio you create the
tree going to tree is your classifier
way of course it's a simple classifier
and makes an error and the sources of
errors are to fault
you may over fit for example if you
don't regularize your tree at all and
you create something that is extremely
specific to the data you'll over fit a
lot which means that basically your
model will not generalize well for that
in classical decision trees they
introduced pruning or you can under fit
and actually it may be the case that the
underlying data doesn't really fit the
classifier that you chose and
it cannot be modeled at all with the
classifier that you have so you will
constantly have this error regardless of
of how different type of parameters you
choose for example for this but for both
cases using the same learner that would
do this under fitting or over fitting
there are remedies in ensemble methods
so Iver you have ensemble methods that
compensate for overfitting or for under
fitting and let's start with the simpler
case with what can we do if we over fit
so Rio Bremen crime came up with the
idea of bootstrap aggregation and
bootstrap aggregation is a very simple
concept to explain you simply resample
your training data that you have with
replacement which means that actually
you don't need any parameters for that
you simply allocate the same number of
slots as you have in your original data
and you randomly pick the observations
so it means that some observations can
be doubled tripled and so on and some
observations will not be very at all
thanks to this when you train a lot of
models on it and your models over fit
each of them over fits in a different
way and when you average them then your
variance part of error
should decrease and if your model
actually makes this variance right that
errors you will never go wrong with
boosting I'm sorry with bagging and
basically you will never go wrong with
it in any case you can just may waste
some computational resources if your
errors are not coming from variance then
the same offer also invented random
forests and random forests has some
additional component it shows us the
also apart from randomness coming from
buggying so
it is when the same youth in the same
bugging framework it also chooses
randomly columns and this trick is done
in order to Decorah late the errors that
are coming in different rounds that you
make so you make errors everywhere but
they have different origins they coming
from from differently created models and
hence it even it is even the deduction
of variances is more emphasized in such
case this was one part another part is
what if your model under fits you have a
very simple model and it cannot really
like reflect the complexity of your data
like let's take a look about at this for
example of adaptive boosting this method
was invented by Robert
Shafi from Stanford University and let's
see but here we have two very simple
classifiers they can divide the space
either vertically or horizontally and if
you look at this data with an Ivor you
can really make a separation so the way
how to create something more complicated
from it which adaboost does is after
each round so it goes sequentially it's
like random forest or bogging could be
done in parallel because things were not
dependent on each other
here you have rounds that one rounds
depend on another round so we start with
an initial fitting of your model you
have some errors then you increase the
weights of these things that you made
error on and decrease the weights on the
things that you classified correctly you
fit your model again you repeat it for
some number of rounds and at the end
based on the errors training errors that
you made on each of these routes
you sum this to your final model and in
this story example you can see if it
actually with this simple classifiers we
created something that is more
complicated but nowadays much more used
in much more known then adaptive
boosting is gradient boosting and the
idea is quite similar it's the easiest
would be to actually presented on a
regression problem you have a regression
problem and you fit some initial
classifier or actually in many boosting
algorithm now adays you just start with
a simple mean of all your data you have
errors coming from from the state and
actually in every route of boosting you
try to compensate for these errors so
you you're not learning the initial
concept you are learning the the errors
so at the beginning we have some initial
residuals we fit the model then we take
together the whole model calculate the
errors again fit to the residuals and so
on and so on and it just conveniently
totally coincidentally happens that
residuals are the gradient of root mean
squared error function hence the
gradient of course the truth is that is
the other way around but it was easier
to to explain so basically for
classification you don't really have
residuals but you have a different loss
function for example for logistic
regression you have logistic loss and
the gradient of logistic loss with not
called anymore residuals because these
are not residuals it's called pseudo
failed or residuals and that's what you
fit but basically the idea is the same
so you fit on the errors and you correct
with each round the error that that was
made and it actually corresponds
to running the gradient descent on your
loss function so we approached eggsy
boost XC boost is just most popular i
believe now implementation of gradient
boosting that wins a lot of cable
competitions and we also use it on
production and we are happy with it
it has interfaces in python are you can
run it on hadoop erm it has some version
for java now you can run it on GPU there
are many new functionalities that they
implement it's still under development
it's not an abandoned project by no
means so new who new features are are
introduced all the time it can be used
for classification regression learning
to run to rank and how it differs from
example from scikit-learn gradient
boosting machines it has a custom
function to build the tree because of
course boosting is a general framework
you can use any classifier inside
like for example linear regression or
logistic regression and boost on top of
it but the most popular and most widely
used our decision trees within the
boosting framework so as i mentioned at
the beginning when you create the
decision trees normally you use some
heuristic function about whether to it's
worth to make a split or not and on
which are able to make this split and in
classical setting Gini index or entropy
is used as a such measure and actually
XG boost requires the gradient and the
Hessian of your loss function and the
all all the splitting and all the
evaluations and everything is done on
your loss function that you provided but
it's actually regularized
and we will talk about this in in tuning
of the parameters but generally it
doesn't use some one approximation for
splitting and another forever for
evaluating regarding certain objective
but you have it just uses this objective
directly to create the trees and that's
one of the biggest differences in
comparison with other methods that are
used some handy thing is that XG boost
has for example you can see the progress
of of your boosting you have the watch
list so you can pass your train and
validation set and you see the progress
every round or every number of rounds
I'll show you this exactly on on some
code examples but this is very handy to
see whether something happens or not how
fast is it going and basically very
handy for debugging especially that for
models where you have a large number of
features and large number of values it
takes quite a long time to train then I
will not cover this with code but it
there is the possibility that you didn't
use enough rounds of boosting and you
still can improve and normally you would
need to start again waste all these
hours in X aboot you can start where you
finished and continue on the other hand
if you over fit it and you used too many
twists at prediction time you can limit
the number of the trees to use and even
over fitted models are recoverable from
I'd say and this I'll show you
okay so so much for the theory and let's
go with some coding
if you take a look at the parameters
default ones
that's the scikit-learn wrapper for XD
boost classifier and that's what we'll
focus on in this coding section it has
certain default parameters three
parameters actually flew all of them
will go in tuning section so for now
we'll just use the default ones on some
data set as a toy data set
I chose 20 newsgroups data set from
scikit-learn if you go through any
example of text processing in
scikit-learn most likely this is the
data set that is used for it I am not
using it in the optimal way because I
wanted to have a certain number of
features without getting exactly into
what it is for now we treat this as a
black box but as I actually run all
these examples and this is a converted
jupiter notebook I also had some limited
time constraints not to use everything
plus some things were changing in
between so that's the reason what
happens here I take the train and the
test in a classical split how it's done
in psych it then then with train tests
split I want to have a separate
validation set so on training set we'll
do actual training within the certain
number of boosting rounds and the
validation will be used at every time as
a watchlist to see how this error also
behaves on this validation set plus we
have a classic test set that is from the
original train test split then tf-idf
vectorizer
a classic feature extraction from
scikit-learn with some restrictions as i
mentioned and you may be curious why
this sparse matrices are converted at
the end because normally scikit-learn
gives you the mattresses that are spa
row-wise and the problem is that this
exhibit which is currently on pip has a
bug and if your last feature in some of
these datasets is missing you get an
error that number of features is not
right because it will not take it into
account and also extra boost internally
it converts it to its own data structure
that is also a data that is sparse by
columns so here is just a conversion to
two column wise sparsity that's how the
data looks like
as you see it's really sparse
two-and-a-half percent density and two
and a half thousand features roughly and
we do some simple classification and
finally think about verbose parameter it
can be true/false or a number so if you
give a number it just gives you every
11th round which is really handy for
making presentations so they even
thought about this then in meetup
description I promise that I'll show you
a couple of equity boost features one it
doesn't really change the way how it
classifies things if you do monotonic
transformations second features can be
correlated and third you can add some
random noise and it will still be as
good let's check if it's true so first a
linear transformation as you know tf-idf
stands for
term frequency inverse document
frequency and ten frequencies are row
based so it's like you applied your
count vectorizer
count the number of times certain words
are ver and then divided by the length
of the document so that's row wise
that's something that is not it wouldn't
be a linear
for example if I used the count
vectorizer but here I say please don't
use inverse document frequency and
inverse document frequency is a feature
of a certain world as the words are our
features it means that it's now I
actually make a linear monotonic
transformation on each column just by
not using the IDF and as you see there
are some slight changes but if you see
at around 33 this is exactly the same so
why it's not exactly the same all the
time potentially because of floating
point operations roundings and another
thing is that this wouldn't explain it
for trainset but for validation when you
do the split and the split is between
two values let's say it's 4 & 5 so if
it's 4 & 5 the split would be under 4
and 1/2 but if for example I would
transform it with mono in monotonic way
by squaring everything it would be 9 and
25 and then split would not be in four
and a half squared so that's another
reason but still this is very very
similar
now as I mentioned Kant vectorizer will
be different but these eyes the
newsgroups data so people sending emails
to certain news groups I would expect
that the length is more or less similar
so these features will be correlated
with an 10 frequency so we use both we
do H stack of sparse matrices we use
both and the results are roughly the
same again so the only problem here may
be when you analyze the importance of
the features because sometimes one
feature will be used another time
another feature will be used and you can
underrate the importance of certain
features because because of it then I
add some random matrix that has exactly
same density as our initial one and
actually it has two times more columns
than the initial matrix so the resulting
matrix has one third of the columns that
mean something and 2/3 of the columns
with a total randomness just with the
similar sparsity and the result is
slightly worse but it's still
inconclusive but it's not immune to
noise entirely because actually if you
try to change the random seed you also
have differences because there are there
is some randomness in this algorithm so
you would have differences as well now
some features watch lists already shown
you early stopping a really cool one so
when you have watchlist of course but
you can use it for is to determine when
you should stop it's one of the first
questions when you ask yourself ok we go
with this rounds how long for example as
long as you have improvements on your
validation set and that was early
stopping is for and then you can also
have when you fit the classifier you
have the whole history like whatever you
want to track you can add whatever
you want whatever says you want and it
shows you exactly what was the history
of learning here is the example of early
stopping it has also some nice debugging
info saying you but now it actually it's
just the second pair that it will be
used for every stopping that's quite
important so for example here I passed
train and validation validation is the
second one good validation will be used
for early stopping on the train because
it would makes no sense
train would almost always improve you
want to find this time when they start
to diverge and in the almost last line
one before you have the example that I
promised you set three limit in
prediction and we said this truly three
limit to be the that really mean that
was had the best evaluation on
validation so a couple of hyper
parameters are solved with watch lists
then some easy way to see how the
learning curve looks like it's the
classic one and that's the from the
example just before so actually after
that what you see here there is no more
improvement it doesn't go up there will
be one case when I'll show you a plot
depending on some parameters when
actually this goes up but normally for
the very long time there will be no
improvement until it actually starts to
go up so you will not observe it unless
you don't run it for really too long
okay so now we'll do some tuning and the
best setting for tuning and actually
determining which parameters are better
than the others would be to make three
times ten fold cross validation with
different seats and a holdout set just
to ensure that you didn't over fit your
cross validation so I just saying you
bet but actually with a bit much simpler
here we just I just have the original
splits and you can't treat everything
that you'll see as something that can be
generalized for other settings and what
we see here so this is the setting for
this particular problem for this
particular feature and also the features
will be analyzed one dimensionally which
in actually in when you do the training
you should take into account all of them
because the optimal values of the
features depend on the other features so
it's like actually a multi-dimensional
problem you cannot do it one thing I
mentioned normally but just to get some
glimpse how things look like
Twitter's like that so some general
parameters that you have the most
important ones is the max depth of your
tree which actually corresponds into how
many interactions you allow to model in
your tree if the max depth is 5 it means
that you can model interaction of up to
5 variables together and also the
difference between that 5 and f 6 in
potential number of the leaves of the
tree it's like with every level it
bubbles so both of the complexity of the
algorithm doubles the time of execution
doubles and more or less of course
sometimes regularization prevents it but
you need to be ready for this
pessimistic scenario of it each level
makes a double
and that's the main complexity
complexity parameter then when I was
talking how one round after an hour you
have favored algorithms no sorry if ever
models that correct each other that's
not entirely true because you shrink it
you don't want the whole model to
overwrite everything you just multiply
it by some constant and then it just
goes a little bit into direction of
correcting these errors and then you
train again and this shrinkage parameter
actually when you have the gradient
descent you prevent jumping from one
hill to another basically if we'll see
how how this effects learning both
parameters I'll show you then Marcus
Delta step this parameter is rather used
is only usable for very very highly
imbalanced classes in binary setting
actually how extra boost handles
multiple multiple classes classification
is that it has one versus all scheme so
it just creates a lot of binary
classifiers so basically if any of it is
highly imbalanced these initial steps
may be very high even if you have small
learning rate because the actual weights
in the leaves will depend on the Hessian
and Hessian can be very small in such
case which would cause two explosion in
weights and this is a cup only for this
particular problem so most likely unless
you have extremely imbalanced datasets
you will not touch this parameter then
number of parameter number of estimators
which is basically number of boosting
routes you can choose the booster it
doesn't have to be tree but I already
mentioned that most of the time we use
trees
then there is some possibility to scale
the weights of positive and negative
samples we can also alter the base score
as I mentioned in this first round we
don't we never reflect the book we never
fit and the original data to the
original score there is some base time
for regression would be like a mean of
all the values and for classification
0.5 so we are totally unsure where to
classify this binary problem then very
often you are required to do something
that is reproducible so you want your
code to when you run it again you want
the same results so in order to do this
of course it's a common case that you
need to set the seed but it's not enough
so when XD boost is in multi-threaded
setting it will not be reproducible plus
there is some unfortunate combination of
software and hardware that I managed to
encounter some time ago that actually
even with single threaded and seed set
it still is not reproducible and when I
found the explanation they claimed that
it could be because of floating-point
arithmetic so but in most architectures
in software if you set it to one thread
and set the seed you'll be fine what -
Twitter's missing normally would be not
a number but if you just read some data
prepared by someone else and they
denoted minus one as missing you can
just alter it here rather than
pre-process the data and then you can
have a custom objective so for
regression default one would be routing
in square or for classification and
would be log loss but basically if you
want to use something else and it is
differentiable to the second degree you
just provide the color ball that gives
the gradient and
and you're good to go just if you
implement this in Python this should be
much slower because original version is
in C++ and the data is transferred only
once if it actually would call all the
time the function from Python it
definitely would be slower so this
parameter that we've seen so far apart
from max depth you will not really tune
normally like this learning rate you'll
set to something sensible the rest of
them are dependable on your data you
don't really - this you don't set five
or ten or hundred parameters and let's
check how it will behave with them
because these are more likely and most
like a settings of event tuning things
but for max def let's see how this
characteristic would look like on our
problem actually the plot would be nicer
so as you see we over fit quite hard
basically like free is enough almost
maybe five and then the trees that are
deeper are the waste of resources
basically so you are not hurt as you see
this doesn't go up but still there is no
point but in case of learning rate you
are hurt and it goes up so you need to
be careful and also one remark from this
plot it would seem that like zero two is
the optimal one not necessarily because
we have the fixed number of boosting
routes here and it's normal that with
it's like it's really like a speed of
learning so zero one speed will
eventually also get there just it
requires more number of rounds but zero
4 and 0 of 6 and so on will rise with
with time so you definitely should not
use it for this problem
you can make a plot like this find
something sensible default one is zero
one basically but very often in some
competitions you may want to even have a
smaller learning rate like zero zero
five and so on because then when this
decimal places of log loss matters then
maybe it will be worth it now the
explanation why I was talking about
random forests bugging and everything
because this maybe could be a little bit
confusing for you but actually these
parameters are something that act
similarly so subsample could be an
analogy with resampling from bugging so
you set a certain fraction and every
round only this fraction of data is
taken into account and it may really
help you with dealing with some nasty
outliers that you have and that drag
your perfect score away so basically
after each round these outliers have a
chance not to end up in your training
set and that's how you can deal with it
then call sample by three I'm not sure
if I mentioned it is in random forests
it was important to de correlate this in
boosting there is no necessity for the
correlation because you don't fit your
models or your algorithms on the same
data however it is still handy sometimes
and call sample by by by 3 or by level
how would it differ by tree means that
in the very beginning you just give a
certain number of features and
classifier can be built only with these
features by level meaning that on each
level at different features are
available to you which means that if you
have some feature but is really dominant
and it's always in the root of the tree
when you use this parameter sometimes
you can push it lower for example
because it will not be available at
creation of root split but it will be
available most likely favored so
how they affect our dataset subsample I
intentionally took this learning rate
1.0 to see if we can deal with this
overfitting nasty overfitting that we've
seen and unfortunately well in this
particular case subsampling doesn't help
so actually as we go through the full
data set our all the errors shrink in
this particular case but of course it
depends on everything on your settings
on your data set so when you tune as I
mentioned it's really a
multi-dimensional problem but here as a
toy examples we analyzed one dimension
at a time then called sample by three it
doesn't improve things but from 0-6 you
see that actually these errors don't
really change and the number of rounds
is fixed so basically it at least it
saves you some computational resources
because the more columns you have that
was the whole reason why I didn't take
the whole TF idea of vectorized stuff
because it was calculating too long for
such a tight presentation and then
called sample by level similar case
because when you have these small
changes just as a homework check your
random seed and assign random seed from
1 to 100 see how things behave you also
have differences so some differences are
just random now the regularization part
so actually that's the formulation of
the of the objective for the boosting
you have the loss function and the sum
is across all observations so for
example in case of regression this would
be our residuals and then you have the
sum over all trees that you've built so
far of the penalty regarding certain
attributes of these trees so basically
you penalize the complexity of your tree
somehow the important part here is that
you cannot
change the past which means that even
what would sum over all the trees the
previous trees are fixed so you actually
optimize only the current tree that you
build and the formula from the paper
looks like this which means that we have
this gamma here gamma T T is the number
of leaves and the gamma is just some
number that you can choose from 0 to
infinity as you see it is loss function
plus regularization function which for
example means that depending on what
type of loss function you have the gamma
will have to be different even totally
different magnitude what is more it is
the number of leaves number of leaves
depends on the maximum depth of the tree
that you have so if you test it for you
try to find the optimal value for your
parameters well then on each maximum
depth this value will be totally
different this is also another thing it
to take into account and it just takes
into account the number of leaves
because in each leaf you have some
weights and the penalty for this weight
is here lambda and basically this is
something very similar that you may know
from Ridge regression so it's l 2-norm
what is not written here in this
objective in the paper but is actually
available is also L one last
regularization so basically also gamma
is sometimes called as L zero
regularization so you have all these
parameters to hold the complexity of
your three interesting parameter is
minimum child weight in classic classic
algorithms that you have for building
the trees you have some minimum number
of observations that need to be
in some note to make a split here it's
the sum of weights but actually some of
sorry some of Hessians and as I
mentioned Hessians for linear regression
will be one which is basically the same
as in this classical settings however
Hessian for I actually checked the code
this is line from C++ or Hessian for low
gloss is used so basically this is the
sum of this weights and its value of
prediction times 1.0 - value of
prediction which has a maximum of
quickly counting 0 25 so 0 5 times 0 5
if you're put for the more sure your
prediction the smaller the value is so
you have roughly you also probably
wouldn't actually tuned for a minimum
child weight because it is constant
that's how it differs from gamma but
when you have a certain path this path
will result in certain sum of weights
there always regardless of other
parameters that you have so you can
actually come up with this for a
regression it's super simple I want to
have at least three observations to make
a split
I just set it to free and gamma very
much depends as I mentioned on the whole
structure of your tree because it's the
number of leaves so you need to
experiment with everything even with
magnitude you can like start your
searching for a good parameter with 0 1
10 100 100 would be actually very good
very high that's what I just mentioned
and last part
why feature important feature importance
is very very significant think so what
are the most important features it's
quite small I will read to you you this
have on with be not our if or so
basically we just make the classifier on
stop words and it still works quite well
and that's why I argue that it's really
important to actually not only tune your
staff with some hyper parameters and
validation and so on because we did this
and still look what kind of features
were significant there there are certain
you we would need to go deeper into this
it may be because of the way how I
restricted the tf-idf vectorizer it
wasn't intended actually that these
features would be used but we have a
nice lesson learned that you really need
to analyze your features and also what
scikit-learn doesn't very much encourage
you when you create the pipelines to
preserve exactly what features went were
but you can do some tricks to still get
get them and know exactly what are the
final features from where they come from
and see if they are sensible because
very often you can create even a quite a
good classifier but I had a story when
we took the magnetic resonance images
and there was a signal coming from the
server of raw fluid and it was one of
the most important features that we had
and when we consulted with the medical
guy and he said that it's basically like
it doesn't have a signal normally it's
just what's like magnetic field of air
so it was totally insignificant and
that's how we debug that we have a
problem
so it's very important one important
thing from here with XC boost based on
trees you cannot extrapolate so
if you have entrain for example maximum
price of something is $1,500 and then in
tests there will be 15 million it will
just treat it in the same way as this
1500 so that's that's the big drawback
it doesn't extrapolate some things about
bugs but we are out of time and I
created this presentation with this
project Jupiter 2 slides it's the
project of the fellow Berliner dots 1
and I really enjoyed doing it so I
recommend you to take a look and there
is a link to github repo and to the
paper of extra boost thank you very much
and I will be happy to answer your
questions
for two questions